bonsoir de la nécessité du secret en
politique et de l'obstination des
historiens à découvrir la vérité tel
sera l'un des thèmes abordés au cours de
ce second numéro des brûlures de
l'histoire puisque le dossier sera
consacrée aux archives secrète
soviétique
ces lourdes portes blindées s'en trouve
en effet sur un formidable trésor des
millions de documents attendre la
lecture des historiens pour nous faire
découvrir des clés de notre histoire
contemporaine et bien ce soir vous
découvrirez entre autres révélations les
liens entre le parti communiste français
le parti communiste soviétique en 1940
et puis dans l'actualité nous ne
quitteront pas le domaine de la croyance
puisque nous parlerons de jésus non pas
le jésus de la pietà de botticelli non
le véritable jésus nous parlerons des
circonstances de sa naissance
jusqu'au mystère de sa résurrection et
nous avons organisé une controverse
entre un passionné de jésus qui croient
en la messianité de jésus est un
spécialiste de l'antiquité historiens
qui lui ne croit qu'aux textes mais tout
de suite le dossier stéphane courtois
patrick rotman
le système communiste a implosé il reste
à comprendre le phénomène communiste qui
a dominé l'histoire de ce siècle a
moscou les archives commence à parler 50
millions de pages stockés depuis des
décennies une véritable mine pour les
historiens avec nous ce soir stéphane
courtois bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de recherche au cnrs vous êtes
l'un des meilleurs spécialistes de
l'histoire du communisme vous avez
travaillé et vous travaillez encore sur
ses archives soviétiques nous allons
voir avec vous ce que sont ces archives
ce qu'elles peuvent nous apprendre notre
histoire et puis nous ne verrons à
travers le cas de jacques duclos
militant exemplaire dirigeants du parti
communiste pendant 50 ans est agent
actif de la liaison moscou paris d'abord
un rappel en images la revue de presse
[Musique]
l'humanité 26 avril 1975 notre parti est
fier d'avoir eu si longtemps dans ses
rangs et à sa tête cet hôtel
personnalité tout de fidélité à ses
convictions et de pureté révolutionnaire
le figaro 26 avril 75 la force de
jacques duclos est sans doute d'avoir
été partout et toujours un militant
exemplaire
le monde 27 28 avril ses contemporains
pouvait d'une manière ou d'une autre se
reconnaître en lui soit qu'ils aient
vécu les mêmes aventures et les mêmes
combats soit qu'ils se réclament des
mêmes racines soit qu'ils aient milité
au kiel minutes encore pour une autre
société
la pravda 27 avril les soviétiques ont
perdu en la personne de jacques duclos à
fidèle ami de leur pays jacques duclos a
participé aux organes dirigeants du
premier interne pendant de longues
années cela vous êtes une passe et
l'hommage de la presse bourgeoise comme
on disait autrefois il ne m'étonne pas
tellement parce que finalement jacques
duclos et est quand même l'un des hommes
politiques français les plus connus les
plus populaires qui a vu la plus longue
longévité puisqu'il avait commencé une
carrière publique de députés des gens
1926 avec une première campagne
électorale en 24 qui avait déjà été très
agitée très connu ils mourraient en 1975
il avait été deux fois vice président de
la chambre c'était quand même
exceptionnel par contre c'est évidemment
tout à fait stupéfiant de voir le figaro
et et la pravda encensé de la même
manière c'est un oui alors la chose
étonnante et que la preuve est le seul
journal à souligner le côté
internationaliste de l'action de jacques
duclos directeur insiste sur son
appartenance au komintern alors voilà ça
c'est peut-être ça le grand apport des
archives de moscou c'est que on a vu
jusqu'à présent la face lumineuse la
face éclairée du personnage et de et du
mouvement communiste et on nous
découvrons à moscou depuis maintenant un
an un an et demi la face je dirais
mystérieuse secrète cachée je dirais
même le côté sombre du mouvement parce
que ce que ce mouvement était avait un
côté sombre
il était rattaché à un régime
totalitaire qui s'est écroulé depuis
quelques années maintenant et or tous
ces éléments là était je dirai au culte
et pas par les adversaires du parti
communiste qui bien entendu tirer à
boulets je n'oserais pas dire rouge sur
les militants communistes mais ça passer
pour de la propagande ça n'était pas
acceptée comme de l'information est
comme une réalité or aujourd'hui nous
découvrons dans les archives que c'était
une réalité et je dirais beaucoup plus
forte que nous les historiens nous
l'avions pensé jusqu'ici alors on va
voir dans un instant ce que sont ces
archives d'abord un rappel en images le
récit d'une vie
à l'élection présidentielle de 1969
jacques duclos obtient près de 22% des
voix le papy tranquille du communisme
séduit au delà de son électorat
traditionnel
il ya des gens
qui n'ont jamais
pendant un demi siècle
ce dirigeant du pcf tribun de talent
leader populaire plutôt si un
responsable de l'internationale
communiste
alliant dans le même personnage la
langue rocailleuse du terroir et l'oeil
acéré de moscou la vie de cet homme
jovial et impitoyable se confond avec
l'histoire du communisme
il est issu d'un milieu modeste de
petits paysans du bea
[Musique]
je garde aussi le souvenir d'un enfant
qui pensaient que cet horizon quand même
ne devait pas être éternel il a fallu
que j'aille mon pain c'est ainsi que
j'ai été engagé et cet artisan pâtissier
j'avais une passion pour l'étude de
l'histoire je savais que tout se faisait
à paris
je m'occupais j'étais intéressé par la
politique et je me préoccupe est de
savoir ce que c'était que le socialisme
parce qu'au fond j'étais en colère
contre la société parce que je
considérais que j'avais été frustré dans
mes possibilités de développement
intellectuel
j'étais allé dans des meetings entendre
jaurès parce que qu'ils ne connaissaient
pas forêt ce n'est ce pas dans mon
village avait entendu parler de jaurès
[Musique]
alors que j'étais au front j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir quatre jours de
permission pour venir voir mon frère
c'est une d'elles cas si il avait eu le
nez et un oeil emporté à bouchemaine
pendant la bataille de la somme pour un
jeune homme de 20 ans qui revient du
front et qui va repartir au front et
j'étais j'avais fait verdun sera bien
utile de vous dire que ça refroidisse
est quelque peu j'avais pu me rendre
compte de ses cibles c'est qu'il y avait
des gens qui étaient fortunés et qui
restait à l'arrière tandis que moi qui
n'avais rien tu étais en avant et
j'étais fort risqué ma peau avec
l'aimable prisonnier en allemagne
pendant deux ans duclos comme des
milliers de jeunes gens écoeurés par la
guerre est ébloui par la révolution
d'octobre les bolcheviks imposent à
leurs partisans d'adhérer aux tests la
troisième internationale c'est la
scission du mouvement ouvrier lénine à
compliquer shiga l'homme comme marcel
cachin se prononcer les représentants
des deux tendances importantes de parti
socialiste s'il prenait position en
faveur de l'adhésion on pouvait 3 une
majorité au prochain congrès du parti
socialiste
[Musique]
en janvier 1921 au lendemain du congrès
de tours duclos adhère à la section
française de l'internationale communiste
il est bientôt sélectionnés pour suivre
l'école des cadres de bobigny où il
apprend le marxisme
[Musique]
après la mort de lénine tandis que
staline commence son irrésistible
ascension duclos multiplie les activités
militant permanent il fait de
l'agitation antimilitariste s'occupe des
anciens combattants mène des actions
anti colonialiste des plusieurs fois
condamnés à des peines d'amendé
[Musique]
et c'est à cette époque là que l'homme
comme henri barkey qui avait milité pour
l'adhésion à la troisième intéressant
est le membre du parti socialiste allez
on les appela pour le jeune parti
communiste les adversaires sont les
socialistes les camarades d'hier devenus
des ennemis de classe en 1926 duclos et
et du député formidable promotion pour
ce petit homme sorti de rien un parti
qui donne de tels gratification mérite
tous les sacrifices en 1928 duclos bas
léon blum couvert par l'immunité
parlementaire il est chargé d'activités
illégales entre les sessions
parlementaires il est contraint à la
clandestinité
vous savez anatole france a dit un jour
tu es un citoyen guidage est en prison
alors que médiocrement son pays
[Musique]
en 1928 le petit jacques effectue son
premier voyage au pays des soviets
l'iran contre staline lors d'un deuxième
voyage il reçoit une formation
spécialisée et devient instructeur de
l'internationale communiste le fameux
komintern comme tous les dirigeants il
répond au questionnaire et rédige à
plusieurs reprises son autobiographie la
fameuse bio dans celle de 1931 retrouvé
60 ans plus tard dans les archives il
écrit je ne suis pas marié je n'ai pas
de compagne en dehors des membres du
parti je n'ai pas de fréquentation je
n'ai aucune relation d'amitié avec qui
que ce soit cet homme se consacre
totalement à la cour
en 1931 l'international l'envoi en
espagne où il purge le parti et impose
une nouvelle direction avec dolores
ibarruri en 1975 la pasionaria pleurera
aux obsèques de son camarade jacques et
puis il va à berlin où le leader
communiste telemann appliquant la ligne
de moscou préfère taper sur les
sociaux-démocrates que sur les nazis on
connaît la suite
le passé
[Musique]
rien à faire puis il ya le parti
communiste
nous avons vu en france l'invité du
péril ses pouvoirs après l'échec de 6
février tentation est bien là nous avons
proposé l'unité d'action est ce à quoi
répondait tellement confuse mans
sentiment d'avoir souviennent que sa
revanche signé le parti d'unité d'action
avec le parc du clos apic la nouvelle
orientation de front populaire avec le
même entrain qu'il orchestrait celle du
classe contre classe il est vice
président de la chambre des députés plus
que jamais dans le même temps il est un
des hommes clés du komintern à son 7e
congrès l'internationale communiste
confirme la ligne à l'international on
ajoute la marseillaise torres revient de
moscou unitaire pour de
[Musique]
démocratie la seule fois peuplant notre
cas la tête dans le développement de la
lutte c'était ça notre idée fondamentale
et ma foi c'est ce fait pas cela tous
nous savons que notre poule à l'enfance
mme après
[Musique]
la guerre d'espagne et claque duclos
fait le lien entre moscou et madrid
andré marty officier dans les brigades
internationales
pendant la course aux abymes de munich à
la guerre le pcf dénonce sans relâche le
danger hitlérien
avec le pacte germano soviétique tout
bascule les consignes arrive de moscou
il faut abandonner la lutte pour la
démocratie et contre le fascisme et non
c'est la guerre impérialiste
le pcf tang puis à proulx duclos n'est
pas troublé il applique la nouvelle
ligne est écrit au président de la
chambre pour demander une baisse
immédiate avec hitler
la presse communiste est interdite le
pcf est dissout les militants sont
poursuivis duclos aux clandestins passe
en belgique
les députés communistes arrêté passe en
jugement
[Applaudissements]
ni avant d'aller
au mans et vous jette dans les bras de
communes et le 15 juin 1940 duclos
arrive à paris dans une voiture
diplomatique avec maurice très en chef
du service des cadres du pcf et eugène
fried instructeur de l'internationale
communiste chargé de suivre le pcr les
allemands sont entrés dans la capitale
la veille
les trois hommes ont perdu tout contact
avec le parti du clos ainsi que
l'attestent une note de fitting chef de
la section étrangères du nkvd à dimitrov
doit se planquer pendant deux jours à
l'ambassade du rsa le 17 juin l'humanité
clandestine titres en français et en
allemand prolétaires de tous les pays
unissez vous une orientation pacifique
marquée par l'éditorial qui dénonce
l'angleterre impérialistes le même jour
le 17 juin m fois c'est un avocat
communiste est abordé par un de ses
confrères proches des allemands qui lui
explique que les communistes pourrait
reprendre une existence légale avec
l'accord de l'occupant fouassin averti
très anc qui prépare aussitôt la
reparution légal de l'humanité le 18
juin très en envoie une militante de
nishino l'un au service de presse de la
kommandantur 12 boulevard de la
madeleine elle rencontre le lieutenant
webber qui prend bonne note de la
demande
ce même 18 juin entrer dans l'histoire
par un célèbre appel les communistes
entame donc des négociations avec les
allemands étonnant pas tant que cela si
on se réfère au contexte celui du pacte
germano soviétique
pas étonnant non plus si lyon lille
d'humanité clandestine du 19 juin qui a
disparu de toutes les collections sauf
des archives soviétiques
ce jour là en effet l'humanité reproduit
sans commentaire un communiqué officiel
allemand
le 19 denis ginola revient à la
kommandantur et dans l'après midi on lui
donne l'autorisation de parution de
l'humanité à condition que les articles
soient soumis à la censure allemande
c'est l'ambassadeur allemand otto abetz
tu qui prend l'affairé en main il reçoit
dans les jardins de l'ambassade trehan
gino l'un et katla la discussion avance
le détail de toute cette affaire est
racontée par duclos lui même dans un
long rapport envoyé à moscou le 2
juillet ranger dans les archives pendant
un demi siècle il permet de reconstituer
sans risque d'erreur toute la
chronologie de ces négociations
a moscou les dirigeants de l'
international s'inquiète torres donne
l'ordre d'interrompre tout contact et
considère du clos comme responsable de
l'application de cette directive
celui ci répond le 21 nous que tout
pourparler on sait c'est ainsi que
l'attestent ce document annoté par
dimitrov un peu plus tard celui ci
informe staline
alors c'est pas une courtois à cette
histoire était connu jacques duclos en
parle même dans ses mémoires il donne la
responsabilité des militants subalterne
mais alors précisément sur ce cas
qu'est-ce que les archives que vous avez
dépouillé nous apprennent qu'ils
permettent d'établir de manière sûre la
vérité voilà on a un cas tout à fait
typique d'une affaire qui fait polémique
en france depuis près de 50 ans c'est à
dire effectivement la tentative de
négociation ou ce qui était considéré
comme une tentative de négociation du
parti communiste français avec
l'occupant allemand en juin juillet août
1940 pour faire reparaître le parti
légalement jacques duclos alors pendant
très longtemps les communistes on y est
purement et simplement que ça se soit
produit et puis dans ses mémoires au
courant des années soixante dix jacques
duclos avait commencé à expliquer la
chose en disant qu effectivement
quelques militants avaient pris cette
initiative
c'était une erreur ils ont été aperçus
immédiatement il avait d'ailleurs été
critiqué et on n'en parlait plus bon et
puis on en était resté là on en était
resté là et j'arrive donc à moscou il ya
un an je demande divers dossiers tu
avais l'air intéressant je les ouvre et
à ma stupeur absolue je découvre donc
des rapports manuscrits manuscrit de
jacques duclos très long expliquant en
détail tout le processus de la
négociation alors évidemment c'est quand
on tombe sur des documents comme ça on
est une photocopie on est véritablement
estomaqué 1 d'autant que duclos n'a pas
envoyé qu'un rapport 1 alors ce qui est
très intéressant c'est qu'en temps
ordinaire le parti communiste français
avait le contact avec moscou par des
postes émetteurs récepteurs il se trouve
que la suite de diverses circonstances
le poste de duclos ne fonctionnait plus
et donc duclos a été obligés de rédiger
ses très longs rapports qu'il a fait
porter par porter on ne sait pas très
bien par quel biais puisque les rapports
ont mis une quinzaine de jours à l'est
de paris jusqu'à moscou mais ils sont
arrivés à ils sont actuellement dans les
archives et on a là un exemple si vous
voulez sur une affaire extrêmement
précises qui se produit sur deux mois et
demi qui était totalement inconnue
c'est-à-dire sur laquelle nous n'avions
aucun élément tangible nous avons tout
le détail de la faire et on voit dans
ses archives que l' affaire remonte
jusqu'à staline alors ce qui est
passionnant c'est que donc duclos
angoisse son premier rapport dès que ce
rapport est arrivé à moscou réunion de
l'internationale communiste réunion de
la commission française débat discussion
télégramme contre télégramme et c'est
tout un processus se met en route pour
établir les directives et les faire
parvenir à duclos mais étant donné les
circonstances c'est la guerre c'est
l'effondrement français cetc
les communications sont très longues et
donc pendant la durée du retour des
directives de moscou duclos lui continue
à négocier de plus en plus avec les
allemands il s'en faire un et alors la
direction de l'international très
inquiète et ne sachant plus quoi faire
s'adresse finalement un staline ce qui
était très intéressant parce que ça
prouve que même pour une affaire
finalement minimes qui concernait le
parti français à une époque où tout
était effondrée et sait où il y avait
quasiment plus de parti communiste
français en france et bien sa remontée
jusqu'à staline et que à plusieurs
reprises dans cette affaire c'est
remonté à staline c'est clairement lui
qui a donné les directives feu vert aux
feux rouges en l'occurrence feu rouge
arrêtez toutes les négociations avec les
allemands vraisemblablement en fonction
de sa propre politique étrangère du
moment et ensuite le dernier document
que vous montrer très intéressant aussi
puisque dimitrov rencontre à la fin en
disant camarade staline aux ordres ont
été exécutés tout est terminé les
négociations donc échoué retournons à
l'été 40 et à l'itinéraire de jacques
duclos la ligne du pcf reste la
dénonciation de la guerre impérialiste
l'allemagne nazie n'est pas attaqué
l'exemple vient de loin puisque le 1er
mai 1941 comme le montrent ces images
des officiers supérieurs de la wehrmacht
assistent au défilé sur la place rouge
trois semaines après les relances sont
armés à l'assaut de l'urss j'ai vécu
clandestinement pigrée vous une première
fois pendant plus de trois ans et puis
pendant toute la guerre et pendant la
guerre ma tête était mise à prix c'était
pas une petite chose et puis non
seulement nous avions alors pendant la
guerre non seulement nous avions la
liesse la peau qui nous cherchait mais
c'est la police de vichy aussi me
chercher nous avions des blondes force
dirigée contre nous
des milliers de communistes combattants
de l'ombre tombe dans le combat
clandestin
[Applaudissements]
à la libération du clos reprend ses
activités de gaulle signe avec staline
un traité d'amitié les communistes
forment le premier parti de france il
siège au gouvernement pèse sur la vie
politique
[Musique]
gouvernement
et président du groupe parlementaire
commune
mais l'union ne dure pas la guerre
froide commencent les ministres
communistes sont chassés du gouvernement
en octobre 1947 les soviétiques créé le
kominform jdanov bras droit de staline
dénonce l'amérique coupable de tous les
maux le monde se divise en deux camps
le pcf choisi le sien sans surprise
[Musique]
les préparatifs de guerre se précise
chaque jour davantage il requiert notre
part une action sans cesse accrue les
français ne veulent pas être les soldats
des impérialistes anglo saxons ils ne
veulent pas être les alliés des
assassins de la bourse grad contre les
lots de stalingrad
non nous ne ferons pas tout ne plonge la
guerre à notre année
au printemps 1952 le pcf organise une
manifestation contre le général
américain reed jouer le soir du défilé
duclos est arrêté dans sa voiture il a
dans sa serviette deux pigeons destiné à
la casserole et suprême imprudence son
carnet où il note tout y compris les
noms des responsables communistes
[Musique]
la police se régale et dénonce le
complot des pigeons voyageurs
toujours fidèle du clos est au coeur de
la purge qui liquident marty et son
camarade de la résistance tillon
[Musique]
duclos n'est pas homme à étaler des
états d'âme lors de ce procès de moscou
à paris il n'en a pas davantage pour
liquider le coeur le procureur de marty
et tillon
[Musique]
quand le petit père des peuples
disparaît du clos en larmes annonce au
comité central réuni ce jour là la mort
du camarade staline
en 1956 dans les soubresauts du
mouvement communiste qui suivent le
rapport khrouchtchev duclos fait partie
du camp des vieux stalinien qui refuse
toute évolution toute autocritique
de retour de moscou ayant entendu
khrouchtchev dénoncer les crimes de
staline il fait encore applaudir le nom
du dictateur dans un meeting
je développe des actions entre les deux
parties et que c'est une icône au delà
de ces refus dans les périodes les
meilleurs en 1934 en 1945 maurice thorez
disparaît mais duclos ne lui succède pas
âgées malades il semble dans une semi
retraite mais il reste l'homme de
confiance de celui
ouvert d'honneur par les russes ils
jouent un rôle déterminant dans la
nomination de georges marchais à la
direction du pcf
jusqu'au bout la fidélité à lui même à
son parti à moscou
ma philosophie de l'homme est la
suivante vive qu'au parlement un vélo
tant qu'ils rôle le vélo tient debout
quand ils ne roulent plus ils tant il se
couche
enfin de courtois il a des côtés
sympathiques jacques duclos très
sympathique avoue avoir votre
documentaire et effectivement on a une
présentation du côté tout à fait
lumineux je dirais du côté tout à fait
populaire même ouvrier il insiste
souvent sur ce point et finalement du
côté très sympathique au sens le plus
fort du terme de jacques duclos qui
était effectivement une des grandes
figures emblématiques du mouvement
communiste français est ce qu'on peut
dire vraiment qu'il a été 7 à u de
moscou sur le pc français cet agent de
liaison aujourd'hui des archives nous
apprennent qu'un c'est tout à fait
indéniable je ne dirais pas qu'il a été
l'oeuvre de moscou il a été l'un des
yeux de moscou parce qu'il y avait
certainement à différentes sortes de
militants français ou internationaux qui
surveillaient le parti français qui
avait des connexions particulière avec
des sphères soviétique bien particulière
dont nous allons reparler alors quand
vous dites ça naturellement si vous avez
vu des traces de solarium bon proche
dans ses archives alors avant d'aller
plus loin nous allons voir maintenant
grâce à un reportage de marcel trillât
moscou justement ce que sont ces
archives et plongé dans les archives
soviétiques
des secrets bien gardés
des portes blindées plus hermétiquement
closes que la caverne d'ali baba et qui
s'en trouvera enfin pour les chercheurs
pendant plus de 70 ans seuls quelques
agents du kgb et quelques historiens
officiels eurent pénétré ainsi dans le
saint des saints au deuxième sous-sol
des archives secrètes du pc us des
millions de documents dormait dans ses
armoires pieusement répertorié
comme ce dessin d'un enfant de 12 ans un
certain vladimir ilitch oulianov un
garçon plein de promesses qui deviendra
un jour lénine
au prix de quelques tracasseries
bureaucratiques les historiens russes et
étrangers ont aujourd'hui accès aux
copies sur microfilms des pièces qui
constituent ce fabuleux gisements
historiques
le français nicolas werth s'est
spécialisé dans l'étude de la tcheka et
du guépéou et ancêtre du kgb et de leur
fondateur félix dzerjinski ce matin la
pêche est plutôt bonne ce sont les
compte-rendu hebdomadaire de la guépéou
de la police politique est envoyé
directement à l'éminent en juillet 1922
et là nous avons un document sur une
grève de typographe à moscou
le 8 juillet 22
avec les raisons pour lesquelles les
ouvriers ont fait grève
le professeur fierce offre recense de
son côté des documents totalement inédit
est plus explosif encore les archives du
komintern l'internationale communiste
en dix ans la moitié de ses
fonctionnaires fut exterminée sûr beau
staline mais l'organisation et son
leader le bulgare georges dimitrov ne
cesseront pourtant de servir de courroie
de transmission aux diktats imposés par
le kremlin au dirigeant communiste du
monde entier destinataire du document
que nous allons découvrir le parti de
maurice torres engagé depuis 1936 dans
une stratégie d'union contre le fascisme
la deuxième guerre mondiale vient
d'éclater
vous voyez ici la signature de dimitrov
il confirme le 8 septembre 1939 la
directive destinée au parti communiste
français
concernant la nécessité de changer
décidément sa position et affirmant que
le seul pays fasciste engagés dans cette
guerre et la pologne pas l'allemagne
c'est pourquoi on ne peut poursuivre la
politique précédente celle du front
populaire celle de l'antifascisme
il faut combattre le gouvernement
français impérialistes
car staline à cette époque
avait des projets fous quant aux
résultats de cette guerre
il pensait que le nazisme était une
force anticapitaliste et que cette
guerre pouvait mettre fin au capitalisme
dans le monde entier
quelques mois plus tard en application
de cette ligne imposée par staline les
communistes français demanderons aux
autorités allemandes l'autorisation de
faire reparaître l'humanité au grand
jour dans la france occupée
un peu renversant quand même est-ce que
c'est vraiment ces archives ses archives
est-ce que c'est fiable vraiment et ce
qu'on peut leur faire confiance oui
alors d'abord il ya une masse absolument
gigantesque d'archivés parler de 50
millions de pages tout à l'heure en fait
c'est beaucoup plus que ça ce sont des
centaines de millions de pages donc déjà
si on imaginait que il a fallu faire des
centaines de millions de pages de fo qui
la plupart du temps ce sont des pages
manuscrites comme celle que montrer
monsieur firent sauf à l'instant c'est
tout à fait impensable d'autre part ces
documents se répondent et se renvoient
les uns aux autres sur chaque affaire
importante il y à des centaines de
documents avec les discussions les
négociations les réunions de telle et
telle commission de tel et tel
responsable et lettres à staline les
retours et c'est donc il est évidemment
tout à fait invraisemblable que ces
documents aient été trafiqués d'une
manière ou d'une autre il faut dire
d'ailleurs que ses archives que nous
avons aperçu à l'instant sont conservés
dans des conditions tout à fait
exceptionnel je dois dire que quasiment
toutes les archives du monde pourrait
venir prendre exemple sur la manière
dont ces papiers ont été percutées tout
et microfilmé comme ça non alors là
nous moi personnellement je consulte
énormément de papier de papiers
originaux les originaux eux mêmes là
nicolas werth accéder à des dossiers qui
étaient vraisemblablement très ancien de
1918 etc qui avait sans doute été
microfilmé pour faciliter le la
consultation mais en fait le chercheur
accède directement aux originaux et je
dois dire c'est tout à fait fascinant de
voir ces originaux qui la plupart du
temps sont à noter comme on l'a vu la de
la main même de dimitrov de man with
kids torres de duclos et c'est encore
encore une question sur ses charges
tedeschi à plusieurs lieux plusieurs
centres d'archivés ce que sont toutes
ouvertes alors il ya effectivement un
certain nombre de centres d'archivés les
deux principaux pour les recherches sur
le communisme actuellement sont celui
que nous voyons le centre dirigé par
monsieur anderson qui conserve toutes
les archives du mouvement communiste et
du parti communiste soviétique de 1917 à
environ
1945-46 il ya un deuxième centre qui lui
conserve la suite c'est à dire en gros
de 46 jusqu'à 91 et puis alors il ya
beaucoup d'autres centres les archives
du kgb les archives de l'armée les
archives des affaires étrangères il faut
bien dire que les archives que nous
avons
allez tout cela encore ouvert voilà
alors celle que nous avons vue là sont
celles qui sont les plus ouverts et je
dois dire qu'on peut vraiment remercier
les les archivistes russe de ce centre
de nous permettre d'accéder avec de très
grandes facilités par contre des
archives essentiel les plus importantes
celles du kgb celle de l'armée et les
archives ce qu'on appelle les archives
du président qui sont en fait les fonds
des secrétaires généraux du parti
communiste soviétique en particulier
évidemment de staline sont pour
l'instant fermé alors dans le dans le
film tout à l'heure on a vu des fameuses
bio que remplissent et remplissez les
militants quand ils allaient à moscou ça
fait partie de ses archives vous avez
beaucoup travaillé là dessus j'aimerais
qu'on les revoit d'ailleurs pour nous
expliquer c'est un instrument de travail
à quoi servent ces bio alors ça c'est
sans doute l'une des choses les plus
secrètes que nous ayons découverte à
moscou c'est tout ce qui concerne ce
qu'on appelle le service des cadres
parce qu'il faut savoir que le mouvement
communiste
d'impact d'un petit parti comme par
exemple le parti communiste belge
jusqu'à de très grands partis et
jusqu'au au parti communiste dans le
monde entier et est gérée je dirais
comme une entreprise comme une
entreprise capitaliste où il ya un
service de gestion du personnel 1 et où
on sélectionne les gens pour savoir
quels sont ceux qu'on va pouvoir
affecter pour telle et telle tâche en
fonction de leurs capacités de leur
fidélité de leur orthodoxie y est cédée
langue qu'ils parlent des connexions
qu'ils ont dans tel ou tel pays et ça
c'est le service des cadres ça a été mis
en place très tôt par les russes et ça a
été ensuite étendu à l'ensemble du
mouvement pour le parti français la
section des cadres est créée en 1932 et
ensuite elle prend beaucoup d'ampleur à
partir du milieu des années 30 c'est à
dire que chaque militant qui commence à
monter dans l'appareil c'est à dire
avoir des responsabilités doit remplir
des formulaires biographique comme celui
ci ou en français le formulaire du
milieu des années 30 est considérable il
fait 74 question donc en 74 question on
a le moyen avec un an qu'on a le temps
de faire le tour de l'individu et pour
les militants les plus responsables
alors évidemment le ils sont rattachés
je dirais directement au service des
cadres de l'internationale communiste
qui est d'ailleurs dirigé en fait part
des russes de la police politique du
nkvd ou du guépéou et donc ils vont à
moscou ils remplissent la des
autobiographies ce qui est encore toute
autre chose parce que là ils ne
répondent pas les oreilles ils ont
rappelé plusieurs dessus il en
remplissent même plusieurs d'affilée on
verra jacques duclos en remplit l'une
par exemple fin 1931 une autre en
janvier d'entre eux les services compare
les textes voix s'il ya des détails qui
viennent qui reviennent qui qui
disparaissent et c est là c'est encore
tout autre chose parce que
l'autobiographie c'est le militant livré
lui-même devant une feuille blanche il
doit raconter sa vie et tout et je dois
dire que ce sont des documents sur le
plan historique très et mouvement et sur
le plan sociologique tout à fait
extraordinaire j'imagine que pour vous
ce n'est que le début d'un long travail
on peut dire on peut dire qu'il ya dix
quinze vingt ans de travail ce sont des
rien que sur le parti français ce sont
des millions de pages donc à vous
imaginer sur l'ensemble de
l'internationale communiste est à dire
environ 60 ou 70 parties dans le monde
entier au tendre autant de documentation
plus tout l'appareil
tout l'appareil interne de
l'international qui comprenait des
milliers de personnes à moscou même avec
des services clandestins de faux papiers
d'argent d'armes etc dans le monde
entier donc on doit s'attendre à des
révélations dans les dix ans qui
viennent sur l'islam et les révélations
ne font que commencer on va aller de
surprise en surprise c'est tout à fait
évident bon et la saône obligé pour ce
soir de s'arrêter là merci c'était pas
le courtois je renvoie
numéro de la revue communisme que vous
dirigez qui vous avez fait un article
d'ailleurs vous raconter en détail à
partir des archives soviétiques nous
publions pour la première fois donc des
articles qui se fonde sur à partir des
archives du club et notamment cette
histoire de la reparution d'humanité
pour ceux que cela intéresse et je
montre deux autres livres hôtel luxe qui
vient de sortir arkadi weissberg qui
raconte l'hôtel luxe était le thème
descendez les communes dernière moscou
est aussi fait à partir des archives qui
s'ouvre à moscou et qui raconte donc
l'histoire de ces communes intervient à
partir des archives et je signale
la sortie d'une remarquable biographie
de boris souvarine que vous connaissez
naturellement qui était un des
fondateurs du parti communiste et aussi
d'un des premiers premier opposant boris
souvarine qui avait écrit une
remarquable biographie de staline la
première d'un première voilà le premier
historien entre guillemets du communisme
à chaud à chose que c'était beau milieu
des années 30 chez robert laffont voilà
merci stéphane courtois
les brûlures de l'histoire suit chaque
semaine nous vous donnons rendez vous
avec l'histoire en images grâce aux
archives pâte est une sorte de remonter
dans le siècle à travers le sport la
littérature la politique et tous les
événements alors une semaine dans le
siècle les archives pathé depuis 1913
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait un corps
les 3 octobre 1973 concorde cet avion
que la france et la grande bretagne ne
parviennent pas à vendre a semble-t-il
réussi son examen de passage aux états
unis les réserves américaines sur le
supersonique étant les plus forts c'est
sur place au texas et à washington que
concorde a démontré qu'il ne faisait pas
plus de bruit qu'un quadriréacteur
actuelle et qu'il ne dégageait pas plus
de fumée
il y a trente ans 2 octobre 1963 depuis
le vol historique de lindbergh on
n'avait rien vu de pareil sur un
aérodrome parisien et youri gagarine a
bien failli à son arrivée au bourget
périr faute d' espace vital étouffé par
un enthousiasme que nous qualifierons
pour plus de commodité indescriptible
[Musique]
inaugurant son 20e voyage en province
par la visite des centres nucléaires de
pierrelatte et de cadarache le président
de la république a dû se soumettre aux
formalités vestimentaire en vigueur dans
le monde très fermé de l'atome non loin
de ce mur du secret le général devait
annoncer son intention de demander aux
français le renouvellement de son mandat
présidentiel
il y à 40 ans le 1er octobre 1958 rang à
quelques jours de l'ouverture du salon
de l'automobile nous avons rencontrés
sur la route du havre à paris ils sont
venus des états unis avec la certitude
d'être la vedette de ce salon le bouton
comme en ouverture électrique du cac
un autre des temples à 5,10 indépendant
pour chaque roue d'autres encore il y en
a une cinquantaine pour les toits et les
glaces un brin de connaître pour les
parisiennes tout est paré
alors allons-nous faire et pendant cinq
minutes
il ya 50 ans
un commando allemand libère mussolini
que le voit avait fait arrêter quelques
semaines plus tôt
il est accueilli par son fils id
il y à 60 ans le 4 octobre 1933
[Musique]
on
répète cependant seul
homme ancien
manager belge
7ème par damabia
[__]
à yushu
participants seuls
abandons
vendeuse chez claire en ce moment autour
d'elle
le même jour départ des forçats pour la
guyane
les condamnés dans un silence que
trouble seulement le bruit de l'organe
of s'avance encadrés par des tirailleurs
sénégalais baïonnette au canon sont
revêtues de l'uniforme de drogués
grilles et portes sur l'épaule un
baluchon maintenant le barda
réglementaire le châtiment commence
vraiment en cet instant en à les
condamner monte escalier de la coupe et
ils disparaissent dans la cale des
caches de fer semblables à celles d'une
ménagerie vont les recevoir pour de
longs jours
il y à 70 ans le 3 octobre 1923 course
de moto au grand prix du stand
[Musique]
tous relèvent de l'histoire y compris
jésus c'est un point d'interrogation que
je vous pose est que nous allons poser
avec claude aziza latini spécialiste de
l'antiquité et puis jean claude barreau
à leur première question jésus n'est pas
né un 11 0 non il est né au moins six ou
moins sept au temps du roi hérode le
grand qui est mort au moins 4 révélation
non non et longtemps qu'on sait que qui
est que j'étais une femme aura 33 ans
mais à 36 37 et conquis l'aîné six ou
sept ans avant l'ère chrétienne
peut-être 40 d'ailleurs si on admet une
dépêche qui viennent le confirmer
maintenant de l'agencement ce presque
d'après un tout récent calcul le premier
le premier jour de l'année moins 720 15
septembre donc en gros on peut penser
qu'il est né en moins cet équilibre
entre en 33 on l'a peut-être plutôt
entendre 3.30 mêlant on peut discuter si
l'on admet aussi qu'on peut re calculer
la date de sa mort qui pose un problème
extraordinaire puisque les évangiles ne
sont pas d'accord les synoptiques les
trois évangile de luc marx ne tient pas
à parler de sa mort si vous voulez enfin
sans le sou il a vécu une quarantaine
d'années voilà alors le physique de
jésus mais bon tout au pam ann jean
beatnik sympathie m'habite n'est que
jésus était un méditerranéen brun un peu
basané nous fait penser au tableau de
bonaparte jeunes par david peu vif pour
le moment pas très grande taille moyenne
enfin un méditerranéen
baa suédois je dois dire que vous avez
c'est pas beaucoup comment vous les
décrivez comme ça mais je vais peut-être
rappeler que
on a donné dès les premiers siècles
différents portraits de jésus assez
bizarrement les premiers pères de
l'église le tenait pour plutôt petit à
la suite d'une erreur de traduction d'un
évangile et en même temps assez laid et
puis à mon avis là je crois que la
première apparition d'un jésus ce blond
avec des cheveux frisés remonte au 8e
siècle non je ne pense pas qu'il était
laid parce qu'il était très admiré par
les femmes dans les banlieues ça
n'empêche pas oui c'est ce que vous
dites aussi il écrivait en fait il
semble là aussi vous vous dites il est
en bonne santé parce qu'il est temps
votre santé parce que la grand marcheur
il fait des dizaines de kilomètres il
n'est jamais banal en face ils mangent
pagaille n'est jamais montré malade il
n'est jamais montré malade mais comment
parle beaucoup de maladies il avait été
malade on l'aurait montré alors 100 pays
galilée samarie judée son pays c'est la
palestine mais surtout la gale idée
dingue à l'idée un
sa vie c'est à nazareth dans la galilée
des collines et puis comme il est il n'a
pas été reçu par sa famille et par les
siens il est descendu sur le lac de
tibériade et un endroit absolument
extraordinaire beaucoup de la nature
très très belle que j'ai d'ailleurs
beaucoup il parle beaucoup de la nature
il admire au bord du lac on avait droit
tient pas laisser songeur quand je passe
en israël ni paul estime à ça me gêne de
palestine parce que c'est interdit après
la destruction du temple eu d'accord
avec vous mais c'est pour que les intrus
il faut que les spectateurs comprennent
serveuse voilà dix ans en gros si vous
voulez qu'il y à l'époque la galilée qui
est sous contrôle des rhodes anti passe
d un doji la période qui est un
descendant des robes de grands que la
samarie c'est une autre chose et la jute
et qui est directement gouvernement omar
depuis plus six après j'ai dit voilà des
révélations sur judas judas était
vraiment un traître je pense que dans la
trahison de judas il n'a pas trahi pour
de l'argent ya certainement en judas
c'est ainsi qu'hier c'est pas ici car
c'est le secteur qui portait un couteau
c'était donc un résistant et il était
lié au milieu de la distance et il ya eu
un grand malentendu entre jésus et la
résistance
puis contre les romains les résidents
ont cru qu'ils allaient prendre la tête
de la résistance et jésus sans condamner
la lutte armée n'a pas voulu prendre la
tête de la résistance c'est l'homme qui
ne voulait pas être roi et à partir de
ce moment là les résistants juifs les
vont se détacher de lui
moi je suis en gros d'accord avec ce que
vous dites en ce qui concerne judas bien
évidemment les 30 deniers c'est une
fable ridicule somme dérisoire et même
si on multiplie par inès et apparentés
s'est pendu voilà et puis judas était le
trésorier de la troupe des impôts de
s'il avait voulu remplir sa bourse qui
n'aurait pu le faire là où je de
trésorerie d'ailleurs alimenté par des
deux grandes bourgeoises des fans de ken
absolument absolument il est d'ailleurs
en les femmes la cncd la norme qui n'est
pas content lorsqu'elle des dépenses
inconsidérées un flacon de parfum par
exemple lui paraît trop cher alain là où
je suis pas d'accord c'est quand je suis
d'accord lorsque les zélotes ont été
certainement bon même si le terme est
anachronique à l'époque les zélotes ont
été en tout cas le mail marchante si
vous voulez de la résistance à rome on
était un peu
fou et ça vous choque pas non moi
j'aurais dit plus tôt mais alors je sais
pas j'aurais dit peut-être la ganassi
voulait c'est-à-dire la résistance à la
résistance lui le risque juive à à
l'occupant lire assez pour faire
comprendre oui c'est de la chronique
mais est ce que je pense c'est que bien
sûr qu'il le lise eliot ont été déçus
par l'attitude de jésus encore que il ya
des thèses qui montrent qu'il était
profondément lié aux milieux elop il ya
deux lots de paris xiiie mais il ne
voulait pas devenir le chef de guerre ça
c'est ça mais là où je suis passé
lorsque vous dites qu'une espèce
d'alliance objective entre le le le sané
drilles le temple et puis les os des
anneaux objectif pour moi dans la
trahison plus tard oui mais ce qu'il
faut dire quand même et bien répéter je
crois c'est que le san et dream c'est à
dire les gens du temple en majorité ça a
été collaborateur ce sont des collabos
là
avec des romains parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent à gagner des postes des
pouvoirs et on n'imagine pas une une
alliance mmm objective entre un parti
zélotes et c'était pas une annonce
formelle mais c'est le fait que les
zélotes ne soutenait plus qu'a rendu une
arrestation c'est vrai alors le procès
le procès c'est le procès jésus c'est le
paroxysme du judaïsme à mon avis et
alors on peut le comparer à socrate qui
est le paroxysme de l'hellénisme et ça a
heurté les autorités
socrates comme jésus vont être condamnés
à mort par les autorités de leur pote
pour blasphème pourri religion au même
âge alors là pour placer la religion bon
alors je crois que deux procès jésus il
ya un premier procès devant le sanhédrin
c'est à dire où il est jugé et condamné
pour blasphème et non pas parce qu'il se
dit messi qui ne pas un blasphème et
simplement parce qu'il reprend la phrase
de daniel qu'il est le fils de love this
de l'homme qui est plus important dans
leur écurie ce que le fils de dieu d'une
certaine façon et que par rapport à pyla
au contraire à pilate au contraire il se
présente comme un enfant qu'on le
présente comme maintenant mais le
problème ddd les autorités juives c'est
qu'elle pouvait pas condamner jésus pour
blasphème il est des plus indépendant et
pilates le planeur romain se moquait
complètement ces étapes de logis il
fallait donc trouver un motif politique
le présenter comme rebelle à l'ordre
romain pour le faire condamner oui elle
l'est encore ça pose toute une série de
problèmes parce que vous savez précieux
on se bat depuis des années pour savoir
si le samho dream pour des condamnés à
mort ou non d'autant plus qu'on se font
sur un texte qui est très clair c'est
que dans l'enceinte du temple il ya une
pancarte en dix ans sera condamnée à
mort tout étranger qui franchira cette
enceinte qu'attendent dans l'eau de
cette histoire ils ont fait appel à la à
la puissance romaine à tout à fait là je
crois que c'est d'ailleurs sans riz ce
sont les romains qui ont condamné et et
ont exécuté jésus il est mort mais
est-il ressuscité alors je dirais que la
résurrection d'une question est une
question de foi ça n'appartient pas du
tout à l'histoire
comment expliquer alors à on en voit
surgir l'historien voit surgir très vite
cette fois extraordinaire
mais il sait pas quelle est l'origine y
peux rien en dire oui je crois que je
n'ai rien à dire et si on peut on peut
prendre les choses de 200 ans au risque
d'être blasphématoire
jésus est mort on le voit après c'est
qu'il est ressuscité ou bien on voit
jésus après sa mort c'est donc qu'il
n'est pas mort je pense que la
l'historien n'a pas à s'engager dans
débat jésus meurt et avec lui
l'historien se tait le christ apparaît
c'est ensuite autre chose oui et sa mort
d'ailleurs et la chose depuis ce temps
certaines de toute l'histoire absolument
car le seul texte antique que nous ayons
qui nous prouve qu'il est mort est mort
sur la croix est effectivement un texte
de tacite voilà merci messieurs je
rappelle titre de votre livre jean
claude barreau biographie de jésus chez
plon et puis très rapidement une
biographie de mère teresa avec sa
conversion à 13 ans une autre conversion
plus tard et puis ensuite son parcours
vers les pauvres que vous connaissez
toujours chez plon un livre au servent
qui s'intitule les voix du coeur c'est
un dialogue entre le dalaï lama et drôle
herman qui est un fonctionnaire de dieu
comme il s'intitule lui même qui a
beaucoup fait bouger les autorités
ecclésiastiques l'année dernière et qui
plaide pour un mélange une union
mystique du bouddhisme et du
christianisme
et puis la passion de madame r c'est une
femme qui vit dans la région parisienne
qui depuis maintenant plus de 35 ans ne
s'alimente pas parce qu'elle est
véritablement en union avec dieu et
qu'elle n'a plus besoin de se nourrir
chez plon aussi merci
les brûlures de l'histoire suit est
presque fin c'est maintenant le moment
de l'éditorial c'est notre façon à nous
de décrypter l'actualité par le biais de
son explication historique ce soir c'est
jean lacouture qui va vous expliquer
l'histoire récente du cambodge
le pouvoir j'en suis rassasié vous savez
la famille royale a toujours régné sur
le cambodge alors moi si je peux prendre
ma retraite même par la prison de laon
drôle et tout occupant
le nom de norodom sihanouk ancien et
très récent roi du cambodge sera retenue
par les manuels d'histoire comme celui
du prince des paradoxes du roi midas à
la reine christine l'histoire des
monarchies est une belle collection de
trait la fantaisie nos disputes
volontiers à l'arbitraire mais le roi du
cambodge peut se vanter d'avoir ajouté
deux figures au parcours imposé de la
virtuosité souveraine l'abdication en
faveur de son père le vieux prince sur à
marib dans 1955 et la récupération d'un
trône après 38 ans pour lui de vacances
monarchique
ses inventions donne la mesure de
l'imagination et de l'audace du
personnage surtout si on ajoute ceux
troisième trait d'imagination historique
avoir été pendant des années le chef
nominal d'une coalition royalistes avec
l'extrême gauche totalitaire et
sanguinaire des khmers rouges
contre une république d'extrême droite
présidés par lon nol en somme l'alliance
de louis saez et de marat contre une
chouannerie républicaine
nous ne posons pas la guerre pour
arriver à avoir un morceau du cambodge
si vaste soit il nous le faisons pas la
guerre pour permettre au néo
colonialisme américain de s'implanter
toujours appelons peine nous faisons la
guerre pour balayer à jamais de notre
sol sacré l'impérialisme et le néo
colonialisme américain
quand j'ai fait la connaissance de leurs
dogmes cela nous qu'au début de 1946 à
phnom penh personne au monde n'aurait pu
prévoir que ce petit roi potelé mis en
place par la colonisation entouré d'un
harem roucoulant de danseuses et
passionné de saxophones serait le héros
est la victime de l'une des plus
affreuse tragédie siècle le massacre
depuis 2002 ce sujet par l'organisation
de polpot dont un terrible mécanisme
mystery faisait son allié objectif
lui qui avait eu le courage et
l'intelligence d'abdiquer pour mieux
diriger son pays le conduire à
l'indépendance ce que la constitution ne
lui permettait pas le faire puis de
maintenir le cambodge pendant près de 20
ans or de l'engrenage des deux guerres
d'indochine n'a pas su s'épargner la
disgrâce de maintenir au delà de
l'inévitable l'alliance de guerre avec
polpot ce qui restera une tâche sur
cette carrière fabuleuse mais compte
tenu de cette erreur l'action historique
de sihanouk sera probablement tenu pour
bénéfique par le peuple cambodgien
l'institution monarchique cambodgienne
vieille de plus de mille ans celle des
bâtisseurs d'angkor est trop liée à
l'histoire de cette nation et
l'expérience républicaine si brève trop
pitoyable pour que la restauration
monarchique ne soit pas considérée comme
une lueur d'espoir par ce peuple
martyrisé
depuis avant de nous quitter voici
quelques coups de coeur sélectionnés
dans le domaine de l'actualité
historique alors tout d'abord les livres
vous le savez cela fait maintenant
trente ans qu edith piaf a disparu le
même jour vous vous souvenez que jean
cocteau de nombreux livres évidemment
lui rendent hommage
le meilleur est celui de georges marc
taille de pierre duclos qui avec une
précision d'entomologiste nous restitue
avec une verve incroyable les tout
débuts d'edith piaf notamment au moment
où s encanailler à belleville et au
moment où elle a commencé son premier
tour de chant ou vel d'hiv alors dans le
domaine aussi de l'histoire des
mentalités de la sensibilité un livre
absolument merveilleux vient de sortir
c'est la biographie de laurence benaïm
sur yves saint laurent alors yves saint
laurent c'est un dieu de notre mode
française il a construit des lignes il a
modifié nos silhouettes je parle de nous
les femmes il a véritablement construit
un univers sensible et cette biographie
ne se contente pas de raconter
l'histoire de yves saint laurent mais
toute l'histoire de la mode depuis 30
ans
puis dans le domaine des expositions
n'oubliez pas de vous rendre à paris au
musée du petit palais puisque nous
français nous pouvons pour la première
fois découvrir les chefs-d'oeuvre du
musée des beaux-arts de l'epci qu'alors
vous le savez sans doute les psys
qu'était un centre universitaire
européen extrêmement important mais
depuis 1838 grâce aux bourgeois de
leipzig il abrite des véritables
chefs-d'oeuvre notamment des
chefs-d'oeuvre de la région rhénane et
comme vous pouvez le voir en ce moment
vous allez pouvoir découvrir
des retables magnifiques notamment cette
magie de la bourre pas un verre 470 et
qui audace incroyable à l'époque mettait
en scène une vierge absolument nu
exposition toujours si vous voulez
comprendre les racines de notre robe
bien chaotique en ce moment et bien
aller au musée national des invalides
car si tient une exposition qui
s'intitule de manière un peu coquine
alliance ou flirt point d'interrogation
l'alliance franco-russe en effet en 1893
une alliance signée entre sadi carnot du
côté de la république française et puis
alexandre iii du côté des tsars essayé
d'organiser déjà une défense entre ces
deux pays est déjà à l'époque on parlait
de l'hégémonie allemand donc vous y
verrez des portraits vous y verrez des
gravures vous y verrez la presse de
l'époque vous y verrez même des armes et
c'est une exposition extrêmement
passionnant pour découvrir ce que nous
vivons actuellement dans le domaine
européen les brûlures de l'histoire et
oui c'est presque terminé mais j'espère
que nous nous retrouverons la semaine
prochaine au sommaire du troisième
numéro des brûlures de l'histoire le
dossier sera consacrée à l'histoire
d'une amitié celle qui unit c'est jean
paul sartre à raymond aron et bien
évidemment à travers l'histoire de cette
amitié extrêmement orageuses nous
aborderons la période de la guerre et
puis aussi la période de mai 68 et puis
l'actualité sera consacrée à l'histoire
de la prostitution l'âge d'or de la
prostitution l'âge des bordels sous la
troisième république jusqu'à aujourd'hui
les maisons de passe mais je ne vous en
dis pas plus les brûlures de l'histoire
bonsoir
[Musique]